Let's do an example. I got this idea from Dan Meyer, a really great math
teacher. The link to his blog is below, with more ideas around the upcoming
example. Let's say you want to go on vacation, but you have a budget of $500.
Where are some places you could go? How much will it cost to go to Reykjavic,
where they have awesome volcanic beaches? Or maybe Dublin, Ireland? Or Kumasi,
Ghana. You'll go anywhere. You just want to have an adventure. You decide to
analyze some flights and plotted the number of miles they traveled and the
costs of that plane ticket. Here's a scatter plot showing the nine flights you
looked up. Here's the line of best fit. This shows the expected value of the
dependent variable, y, for any value of the independent variable. Let's focus
on this point, for example. For this x value, which looks like it's about 1,500
miles, we see that the flight costs almost $800. Let's say this is about 750
dollars. This is the observed value. But based on our line of best fit, we
would expect that a flight that travels 1500 miles would cost more like 450
dollars. These expected values for any x value are symbolized by y hatt.
Whereas the observed values are just are regular y values. You can see that we
have an observed and expected value for all of these data values. Take this
one, for example. We travel about 5,010 miles, let's say. And the actual or
observed price was about $1500. But according to our line of best fit, we would
have expected this to cost about $1200. The prices for both these flights were
more than we would have expected based on all of our data. The difference
between our observed and expected value is called the residual. There's a
residual for every point in the data set. It might be 0, or it might be huge.
The most important thing is that we're able to find this line of best fit and
then use it to visualize the data and the relationship between x and y, and
make predictions.